انقطاع غزه الذي يمر في ظروف ماساويه
وكارثه هذه الايام اتوجه لكم بالتحيه
والتقدير
باسمي وباسم كل الصحفيين الفلسطينيين بل
باسم شعبنا الفلسطيني هنا في قطاع غزه
بالتاكيد هذه الاوضاع التي نعيشها اوضاع
صعبه جدا و كارثيه جدا و باعتبارنا شريحه
الصحفي
الاثمان التي ندفعها في هذه الايام في هذه
الحرب هي اثمان باهظه جدا ومؤلمه جدا
وموجعه جدا وبالتاكيد كلكم تتابعون ما يحل
بالصحفيين نحو 110 من الصحفيين استشهدوا
في قصف اسرائيلي خلال ثلاثه اشهر وهذه
ارقام مرعبه
وماو وغايه في صعوبه بالتاكيد هذه الارقام
لم تسقط حتى حتى في اعتى الحروب التي
تابعتم وها وتابعها العالم كله بما في ذلك
الحرب الفيتناميه التي استمرت 20 عام لم
يسقط فيها هذا العدد ومع ذلك يعني ما زلنا
ندفع ثمنا باهظ ومؤلما مازلنا ما زلنا
نتجرع هذه الاوجاع الكبيره جدا من دمائنا
ودماء اولادنا وابنائنا وسرنا
ومقدراتنا ولكن بالتاكيد هذا لا يثنينا عن
المضي قدما في مواصله هذا الطريق وفي
مواصله حمل هذه الرساله الانسانيه النبيله
التي كفلتها كل المواثيق والقوانين
الدوليه ومع ذلك الاستهداف مستمر هذه
المقتله بحق الصحفيين ما تزال مستمره
اتمنى ان يكون ان تكون دماء الشهيد حمزه
ابن ولد الك هي اخر الدماء في هذه المقتله
التي يتعرض لها الصحفيون
الفلسطينيون